[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIKKI METTEBA: Being
at Princeton University
is really exciting, especially
when I'm walking places,
and I know that there have been
indigenous people before me who
have walked there too.
And knowing that I'm able
to reclaim those spaces,
it's empowering.
CARMEN LOPEZ: Our goal
at College Horizons
is to increase the number
of Native Americans
that are accessing
higher education
both in the undergraduate
admission process
and in the graduate and
professional school.
KEVIN HUDSON: The Admission
Office here at Princeton
was instrumental in bringing
College Horizons to campus
this summer.
College Horizons
is a great partner
as we think about
the role that we
can play in increasing
the number of students,
Native American students
and lower-income students,
that consider Princeton
as an option.
MIKAELA CRANK
THINN: Students get
to really have that
first on experience
with living in the dorms, being
in these classroom spaces,
utilizing the campus, and kind
of having that impact of what
it might be like
to be at a place
like Princeton or any
other institution.
KEVIN HUDSON: The reason
why that's so important
is because oftentimes
students don't see Princeton
as a school that's theirs,
that could be their home.
And by getting students
here over the summer
to be exposed to the campus,
to meet administrators,
to meet faculty, and to
leverage the opportunity
to be on campus,
it lets more students
know that Princeton
can be an option for
them and a home for them.
JEFFREY FIFE JR.: We are the
leaders of today and tomorrow.
So Native youth have such an
important role in the community
by taking initiatives that some
others wouldn't necessarily
take.
I believe that if we lead
the way in higher education,
others will follow.
KEVIN HUDSON: I was
participating in a college
fair, and a student
ran out and asked
to hug, it was
actually the director,
and share the joy he felt
because he had found his 15
dream colleges.
And to see the joy on his
face is the type of experience
that we want College
Horizons students
to have and to take
away and bring back
to their communities.
MIKAELA CRANK THINN: We want
to make college relevant
for our students.
We want them to know that
colleges is not necessarily
just the name or
necessarily about, you know,
what the colleges offer,
but what our students
can offer to those colleges.
JEFFREY FIFE JR.: They're driven.
That's what Native youth are.
We are driven.
And I believe we will change
the world in many ways.
[MUSIC PLAYING]